all right so yellow jackets is now in
full force weird mode with some of the
things that happened here in episode 2
especially the ending I advise not to be
eating while watching this but welcome
back to heavy spoilers in this video
we're going to be discussing everything
in this latest episode things you might
have missed some callbacks and potential
theories we have there's something weird
and it don't look good anyway if you
enjoyed this video hitting that like
button is much appreciated and subscribe
to join the Lottie Cult of spoilers as
we're going to be covering this weekly
with all of that out of the way thank
you so much for clicking this I'm your
host Jared now let's get into
Yellowjackets episode two so kicking off
episode 2 Shauna and Jackie are back in
the meat shed arguing over essentially
life which is basically just Shauna
arguing with herself if you remember
back last week Shauna ate Jackie's ear
being the first to taste the crunchy
cartilage of human flesh and this whole
scene is her questioning her decisions
her eating Jackie carried more than just
the remedy for Hunger but rather
identity Shauna honestly is kind of a
blank canvas of a character looking back
at season one and her eating Jackie can
be chalked up as her becoming Jackie
this helps explain why she has the same
life Jackie wanted as an adult but here
she's torn by her actions of eating
Jackie feeling guilty of course a bit
conflicted which leads to her plain
life-sized doll with the lifeless Jackie
doing her makeup hair and posing her
while on the other hand Shauna takes a
nice chunk of meat out of her forearm
without knowing it seemingly
instinctually she's riding this thin
line of morality that we know tips more
towards wrong in Shauna's later life
outside of the Wilderness however
Shauna's meat shed play time
you know okay don't don't Google that is
cut short with taisa discovering the
[__] up situation she has going on
calling for it to stop demanding they
get rid of Jackie's body via cremation
this is obviously a revelation for
everyone especially coach Scott
would have been my same reaction buddy
begrudgingly this is the decision which
we'll come back to later but also you
can see the differing factions of girls
slowly forming with tensions building
everyone has obviously had enough of
everyone especially when it's in the P
bucket but taisa is slowly leading one
side of things with Lottie having her
followers on the other the Lottie side
of things includes Travis Van Misty and
Crystal seem to really believe in the
Supernatural mumbo jumbo Lottie is
spitting out thinking she knows more
than the others even van who is in love
with Tai is firmly in lottie's corner
present at the bear heart ritual at the
end of season one and still wearing the
deer bone protection necklace suggesting
taisa talked to Lottie about her
sleeping problems Travis continues to
get lottie's blessing before hunting
despite Natalie's loss of Faith Taissa
and Natalie are the two that are firmly
in the other corner against lottie's
teachings and honestly being more
logical and reasonable about things so
yes tensions are running high but also
this could be seen as a divide amongst
science and religion because there are
already been several instances of
religious symbolism well some of it can
be logically explained like taisha's
supposed dirt eating actually being Pika
while other stuff not so much Natalie
has been suspicious of Lottie ever since
the Seance night back in season one and
it doesn't help that she keeps urging
Travis that Javi is alive which honestly
we we don't know yet but yeah this the
odds are very slim never tell me the
odds out hunting the pair even Parts
ways A visual representation of the rift
of each of them following their own path
with Natalie suggesting that they meet
back the weird bossy tree we still don't
know the meaning of this from last week
maybe it contains some sort of power I
don't know let me know in the comments
but one major thing Natalie does is
essentially stage javi's death for
Travis to finally have some closure it
looks like Natalie had snuck into javi's
suitcase took a pair of his pants and
made it look like she found a piece of
his drawers torn and bloodied suggesting
Javi is no longer someone to worry about
or he ate Taco Bell right before the
flight I get it Natalie is trying to
keep Travis focused on the present but
honestly it's it's hella messed up like
what if Javi does just come back out of
nowhere Natalie has got some explaining
to do even back at Camp Natalie and
Lottie get into things with Lottie still
believing Javi is alive and out there
and Natalie basically gives her the you
shut your mouth when you're talking to
me bit so the sides have clearly been
formed but part of me really wants to
see Javi just casually roll in one day
and just everything turns to all sorts
of chaos now this Rift between the pair
is still very much alive in present day
and yes it was confirmed Lottie is
running a cult or rather a wellness
Retreat depends on your point of view
but the man being buried from last week
was in fact a re-birth ritual so I'm
chalking that up as a win Lottie reveals
Natalie has been in and out of rehab
five times meaning the rehab centers
have maybe been hers or she's been
keeping tabs on her ever since the
Wilderness which would explain why her
purple goon squad was sent to her at the
end of season one when she was trying to
end her life last episode I talked about
the color meaning of the purple and
orange worn by the followers and Lottie
and here it's revealed that they are
dyed in-house with heliotrope flowers
and after a quick Google search
heliotrope means to move with the sun in
reference to the flowers that followed
the light of the sun throughout the day
so a Lottie here symbolizes the Sun and
the followers are the flowers following
her wow deep
I don't know anyway we finally discover
what happened with Travis back in season
one and how Lottie was involved with
things even 25 years later Travis still
believed in lottie's Powers if you will
and the Wilderness power is calling out
to him essentially past trauma is
haunting him and he desperately needs to
talk to it or understand it so he
literally pulls a flatliners you know
the hit 1990 movie where med school
students see how close they can get to
death to help them understand the power
of the afterlife Travis here does the
same hanging himself with the help of
Lottie Travis was the one to set all of
this up the candles the idea there
wasn't Foul Play like Natalie thought
even though part of me thinks Lottie is
leaving out some key information
especially the reasoning behind the bank
information cleaning out Travis's bank
it's all an accident a bit uh
anti-climactic but this does give more
evidence to the supernatural Powers
having control over them and influencing
events because the lift begins to rise
even after the button malfunctioned
Lottie sees a vision of Laura Lee
approaching Travis similar to her
showing up at the end of season one when
Jackie froze to death things get hella
weird as there's also glimpses of
lottie's baptism from season one ending
on a horrifying sound of the plane
crashing and Laura Lee turning into
Violet Beauregard with a terrifying look
on her Violet now blue face why Laura
Lee turns blue is beyond me but there is
this crazy out there Theory as to why
Lottie sees this it's because of her
head being smashed in from season one
during the Seance and this caused her
third eye to open therefore seeing
things on a different plane now the
third eye or the mind eye is sometimes
associated with religious Visions for
example seeing Laura Lee and also the
visions of her baptism but also gives
the person the ability to observe
chakras auras precognition and out of
body experiences so this could explain
why Lottie has these abilities or
supernatural abilities if you will While
others cannot see them and weirdly
enough Laura Lee had similar like
abilities with her third eye being
opened in season 1 flashback when she
dove into the pool hit her head and the
Lifeguard rescues her way out there yes
I know but think of all of the weird
things Lottie has already seen and done
it could mean she's on a different plane
of existence and ties back to the last
episode with her giving the speech in
the opening about things not being real
Natalie unfortunately has to stay at
lottie's compound because it's too late
in the day for the train however this
Vision that she sees right before going
going to bed is intriguing it looks like
she's being resuscitated after one of
her potential past overdoses the two men
here are clearly paramedics but the man
pacing by the door honestly looks like
Travis the two may have partook in
recreationals together in the past and
this addiction is what caused a rift
between the pair Misty throughout this
episode seems to have a fairly
straightforward run of events compared
to the others she's trying to connect
with the others because of Natalie's
Foul Play suggestion while going back
and forth with the mysterious citizen
detective on the subreddit later at work
Elijah Wood's character of Walter is
seen by Misty and she receives a
mysterious invisible ink letter from him
he seems to be on the same wavelength as
Misty eccentric but very knowledgeable
and sneaky about things so I could see
these two forming a mutual bond moving
forward especially if she goes back to
the motel and pretends to be an FBI
agent with him that right there might be
the most intriguing part of her
storyline in this episode setting up
this mysterious person at the motel now
what if what if it's Jeff trying to turn
in Shauna behind her back but speaking
of the authorities Shauna wasn't as
careful about Adam Martin as she might
have hoped because Kevin tan questions
her about their relationship Annie and
all of Misty's teachings from episode 1
are thrown out the window because uh
yeah the text message records are not in
her favor Kevin was there as a friend of
course and I think he's going to side
with her after all of this settles his
tone didn't necessarily imply nefarious
purposes Cali on the other hand is the
one who Shauna needs to keep an eye out
for sure she helped her get rid of Kevin
by making him leave with an excuse but
still holds Adam's burnt driver's
license as like a bartering chip this
could be the thing that finally causes
Shauna to revert full on feral
Wilderness against her own family Shauna
is not a good person at all and slowly
seeing how she treats others especially
even her family it's a full-on implosion
ready to happen breaking the Jackie mold
she is living in I thought this line
from her was going to be a turning point
but nope Callie
cows
at least go through the back in case
he's still out there
and the more Cali learns of the inner
workings of what's actually at play
allows her to hold more and more power
over her mother because Jay at the bar
seems to be a potential romantic
interest moving forward solely for
information from his standpoint but then
actually begins to like Cali she learns
of the truth gets mad and he turns and
fully loves her the classic Fern Gully
Avatar turn or at least that's my guess
as to what's going to happen but with
Jay slowly Gathering undercover Intel
Shauna's days are numbered oh oh and
it's fairly telling about the two words
Cali suggests for the crossword being
satanic and ceramic both relating back
to her mother because of her past and
the ceramic rabbits she owns taisa might
have the wildest journey and reveals of
this episode though and just a heads up
I know in the last breakdown video I
completely butchered her name that's on
me I have a tough time with pronoun
enunciation but that's neither here nor
there anyway getting into it that no
eyes man makes another appearance
guiding taisa to her death as she
sleepwalks Into the Wilderness now this
mother trucker has made a couple of
cameos and I think it's supposed to be a
harbinger of Doom or death here he leads
taisa to a cliff and back in season one
her grandmother saw him right before her
death looking at dream interpretations
yeah we're inceptioning this one meaning
of someone without eyes could tie in
with them feeling like an outsider from
others in this case in the wilderness
taisa is not on board with Lottie or her
little Clan's ideals telling van not to
associate with her while in present day
she's newly elected and all of this is
foreign to her while she is on the outs
with Simone and Sammy speaking of these
two though taisa again shows she is
fully unwell in her current role as mom
caregiver and state senator because her
sleep Persona is slowly taking over her
life when Simone comes over to pick up
Sammy it soon realized that taisa had
completely hallucinated the entire time
Sammy was never at the house which makes
me wonder how many other times has this
happened and she is entirely unwilling
to get help for her situation earlier
when she's on her coffee binge Montage
the song inertia creeps plays which
pretty much sums this up because it's
about being dishonest to yourself and
dishonest to the other person being in a
situation but too weak to get out of it
that's where taisa is now what I really
think is happening with her is a case of
multiple personality disorder
potentially did There's multiple reasons
I lean this way one of which is her
turning in the mirror without her
actually turning like there's a dual
personality here last season Sammy he
also mentions to taisa that there is a
good and bad person and he doesn't like
the bad one the smile of taisa at the
end of season 1 also speaks of something
sinister lying underneath and lastly
when we discover Sammy was never there
to begin with and is still at school in
the car taisa has a change of face when
Simone is berating her instead looking
to see the cross traffic and
accelerating to actually cause the crash
taisa is slowly having another
personality take over an aggressive one
which even explains the altar from
season one but she has no idea that this
is happening back in the wilderness the
girls prep Jackie's body for a
ceremonial Jedi funeral and again
tensions run high as they argue about
keeping Jackie's jacket or not and I
mean like
she's not gonna need it Shauna has some
final words and gets as much closure as
she can two noteworthy things though one
is that Lottie sees the cut on Jackie's
arm kind of giving Shauna a look of a
your secret is safe with me so I'm 99
sure Lottie knows of Shauna's snacking
habits the second thing though is the
passing of Jackie's necklace to Shauna
obviously a Keepsake to remember her by
but in the opening of season one with
the death of the pit girl this
mysterious pit girl is seen wearing the
same necklace so how it's passed from
Shauna to whoever is going to be an
interesting game of musical necklaces
because I'm dead set on pit girl being
merry similar looks between the two but
why the necklace they like that some
beach up Jackie is toast literally and
Travis Burns javi's pants as a sign of
finally moving on hobby is no more this
leads to Natalie and Travis having
intimate moment with one another but
during all of the smooches and grinding
Travis sees glimpses of Lottie as
Natalie similar to the weird Visions
from episode 1. this happens when
Natalie caresses his chest similar to
how Lottie did I view this in a similar
manner as how Laura Lee was too Lottie
being this guidance Shining Light if you
will hell maybe Travis even has the hots
for Lottie but right now it's a bit
cloudy what isn't cloudy is the
Wilderness is made out to look like it
has a mind of its own weaving through
the trees breaking a branch dropping
snow on Jackie preventing her from
burning but rather creating a natural
smoker this is shot in such a way that
it could be a mysterious Force causing
this or simply the branch broke either
way though causes Jackie to become
essentially a smoked Pig causing
everyone to wake to the delicious Aroma
of Jackie's charred carcass radiohead's
Cree creeping up the walls kicks in
which is another bang on musical Choice
meaning being in a state of agitation
through stress or worry of course them
worrying about hunger and the worry of
them actually eating jaggy but Shauna
insists her baby wants them to now this
final minute is weird like weird because
it's all of them now dressed in ancient
Greek dress headpieces sitting around in
Exquisite Feast now I instantly thought
that this was some sort of religious
forbidden fruit symbolism but with them
dressed in Greek garm this is more
closely tied to the bakai which is an
ancient Greek tragedy involving Dionysus
and his main ads a quick overview but
the story basically follows pentheus the
king of Thebes one of the oldest cities
in the world denying the worship of
Dionysus therefore Dionysus sends his
followers or remain ads to rip and tear
apart pantheist in an act called spare
essentially this is what's happening
here at the end when they rip apart and
eat Jackie Dionysus is the god of the
grape Harvest wine making Orchards and
fruit vegetation fertility festivity
Insanity ritual Madness and religious
ecstasy which is all present here and
the main ads were typically in a state
of ecstatic frenzy through a combination
of dancing and intoxication which sounds
awfully similar to the Dooms Coming
Night from season one and during these
rites the main ads would dress in Fawn
skins and usually carry a long stick
wrapped in Ivy and Vine leaves tipped
with a pine cone again similar to what
the girls are wearing during the Dooms
coming Rampage even in the bakai they
hallucinate their human prize is that of
a lion similar to the girls believing
that Travis was a stag back in season
one a lot a lot to unpack here believe
me but the story threads and
similarities it's all there but black
and white clear as Crystal coach Scott
is the only one not to partake in this
eating of Jackie so he's already on the
outs and he's wounded so most likely
he's going to be the next in line to be
eaten Misty's finally going to get a
taste of that delicious rump roast she's
been craving I'd like to put some
barbecue sauce on that button because
anyway that is episode 2 of season two
we did get this episode early and
unfinished for review so if there are
some major differences please let us
know in the comments the only ones that
I seem to notice are a few minor VFX
shots but I'd love to hear your theories
and of course let us know if we missed
anything in the comments and I'll let
you know we're currently running a
competition giving away three copies of
the Superman collection on the 15th of
April and all you gotta do to get a
chance of winning this is like this
video subscribe with notifications on
and drop your thoughts of Yellowjackets
episode 2 in the comments below we pick
the comments at random at the end of
every single month and the winners of
last month are on screen right now so if
that's you message us on Twitter at
heavy spoilers if you want something
else to watch be sure to check out some
of our other cool videos right over
there we're cranking them out but with
all of that out of the way thank you for
your constant support I've been Jared
I'll see in the next one take care and
peace